new medical research shows that men and
women have different food cravings men
preferring meat and women preferring
sweets scientists trace this back to
caveman days when men had to go out and
hunt for food while women sat on their
fat asses eating chocolates
[Applause]
[Music]
did you just sell yourself maybe it did
sound a little wet didn't it right the
end and I've been criticized in the past
for having a go at fat people I've never
had a go at fat people I've only ever
pointed out the fact that you get fat if
you take in more calories than you burn
off that simple science I don't judge
them in any other aspect of their life
but that's what happens you get fat if
you take in more calories than you burn
off okay and that that's indisputable
okay now the thing is people think I'm
having a go I'm not because I don't
judge them if I see a fat person I don't
make assumptions about other than how
they got fat and this is the other thing
they not know wait wait but not only is
that what makes you fat people know
that's what's making her fat no one got
fat behind their own back no one and
then went what the [ __ ] that okay it's
not a surprise it's a gradual process
you have loads of time to back out from
this project and also no one's sneaking
into thin people's apartments and
injecting their lettuce with a million
calories that doesn't happen okay
they know what stuff you got to blow
when he's surrounded by cakes and pies
right and you go you know it's making
you fat don't ya he doesn't go who's all
the running he knows what it but I don't
make judgments okay other than how they
got fat okay if I see a fat person I
don't go all he's fat therefore he's
jolly right a lot of miserable aren't
they if
if I see a fat girl I don't go all she'd
be pretty if she lost weight that's
rarely the case okay
so don't fall for that okay for a lot of
them started eating because they had
fuck-all to lose so no but there's no
stigma attached because it that people
don't even want to use the word fat now
because I think it's derogatory it's a
real taboo subject they use euphemisms
they go oh you know Brenda the big girl
what seven foot no no not what she look
like Brenda you know she's the one who's
clammy even in winter just say she's fat
nothing wrong with it it's their choice
up to if you wanna be fat it's fine they
don't like a you know Brenda them she's
out of breath just standing up at her
desk just but even though it is their
own fault and it is their own fault I
feel sorry for them right now I do
particularly particularly fat women
because fat is a feminist issue men get
fat and we just go [ __ ] it all bought
and paid for you know we don't come
under the same constraints of society or
as women are inundated with images of
how you should be size zero models this
diet that diet look like this keep your
man and then make such an effort don't
like fat girls therefore it's got lovely
hair although that was having their hair
don't got lovely hair was got lovely
hair always got those lovely false nails
they make an effort anything but jogging
right
they love high heels don't they they
think it makes their legs look less it
doesn't it just you just hear him coming
now I don't want any fat people to feel
uncomfortable one of my gigs so next
time buy two seats I'm Jung joking I'm
best I'm Jo Giada I'm not having a go
I'm just pointing out you know I was
listening to the radio in England a few
weeks back radio for quite highbrow
there was discussion about political
correctness my name came up straight
away all right and there was his phone
on there going oh yeah well it's it's
not right I'm Ricky Gervais is um he
makes jokes about fat people he wouldn't
make jokes about gay people woody and
being fat is like being gay
what no it's not what you can't choose
your sexuality as we've established you
choose whether to eat too much or not
you know yeah with with with your
sexuality you're born you grow up you
discover you like same-sex relationships
and that's it you're gay okay
but being gay to be the same as being
fat you'd have to be born be straight
grow up knowing you're straight but
gradually and consciously wean yourself
onto [ __ ]
Oh happy 16th birthday son
this is Rowell suck his [ __ ] sorry
father
suck his [ __ ] 16 now suck his [ __ ] I I'm
heterosexual all with his newfangled
words suck his [ __ ] come on
I don't like [ __ ] father doesn't like
[ __ ] how do you know if you've never
tried it
ah suck his [ __ ] I've got suck a one
[ __ ] sucker that's not sucking it that's
playing with you put it in your mouth oh
how that goal you might like it
oh it's not so bad is it oh I [ __ ]
love these if that happened then being
gay would be the same as being fat but
it doesn't so it's not okay Janee sexual
Gabriela she needed a bigger house ginny
sacrimoni what she needs is her own zip
code
Jersey is a small state she moves in she
could tip it over I like a woman you can
grab onto something you've grabbed onto
ginny sacrimoni your [ __ ] hands all
disappeared she's so fat the blood type
is ragu she's so fat she goes camping
the Bears have that idea for guess who
guys go [ __ ] at the same time and
still never me on a talk show recently
Joey Buttafuoco's said of Amy Fisher I
hope she gets hers and dies in prison
like Jeffrey Dahmer and when she does I
will go out and eat cake
moments later however he admitted look
I'll be honest with you even if nothing
bad happens to him you fish or I'll
probably go out and eat cake
ladies and gentlemen I'd like to talk to
you about men that like obese women I'm
not talking about men that like women
with a full of figure that seems
entirely normal natural and right more
cushion for the pushing as I believe
people say I think that's the expression
now I'm talking about men that like
women who are can't leave the house fat
so I'm not talking about anyone in here
this evening unless in order to get out
someone have to cut the side of the
house off and there were some sort of
winch involved I'm not talking about
people with water retention I'm talking
about people with cake retention people
that tell you they've got a thyroid
problem you sell really a thyroid
problem what are you taking for that
pies
[Applause]
you know the kind of girl that looks as
if she makes a cracking breakfast but
wouldn't want to share it with you I saw
a thing on TV the other day she was on
one of these kind of makeover shows that
are on during the day they did a
makeover on a girl she was 34 Stone
it's like rearranging the deck chairs on
the Titanic I say a makeover they gave
her a fringe is that really gonna turn
the corner for a girl like that that's
what I'm asking I don't think it will I
can't imagine a scenario where a guy you
know he's drinking in a bar he looks
across he sees a girl she's 34 Stone be
tough to miss her let's face it he
thinks to himself she's a little bit big
for me goes back to his drink meanwhile
the makeover team are in snip snip snip
he looks back he thinks actually on a
wood it's the excuses that get me the
excuses are amazing the camera adds 10
pounds
stop eating [ __ ] cameras
the reason I've become obsessed by this
topic is because of a couple of
documentaries on TV there's one called
fatties in their feeders anyone see it
it's an amazing sociological study of
obesity in our country and the health
problems inherent in that and also it
was [ __ ] hilarious it was basically
these tiny little stick thin men
bringing massive KFC buckets of food to
these enormous women that couldn't even
move and while we're on the subject you
be careful with the KFC bucket it's a
big leap from plates to bucket but from
bucket to trough not very far at all the
other one that was on was called chubby
chasers I like the title chubby chaser
sounds great I just wonder how accurate
is that how much chasing is actually
going on Lavelle waddling and wheezing
then gotcha gotcha my sexy body my sexy
mom eats in line of sex a montage by the
way would you like some chicken I've got
more no thanks the New York Post is
reported that Michael Jackson wants his
closest friend in the world Elizabeth
Taylor to be the godmother of his child
however those close to the fair worried
that this could eventually lead to
heated arguments over whether the chow
the child will be molested or eaten
[Laughter]
this girl was no bargain either she was
fat but when she wears high heels she
strikes oil oh I don't really have a
shot with him I think because I just
don't rate movie stars I'm not really
[ __ ] fat it's ridiculous
like I have this problem now my pants
keep like I can't keep them as they
won't stay up because here's what
happens okay you get fat and some of
your skinny people won't I don't give a
[ __ ] about you you won't get this
I hate skinny people because they don't
empathize with fat guy problems they
just don't like you remember skinny
friend you're trying to tell them like I
just I just wish I could have one donut
and [ __ ] walk away I wish I could do
that I wish I had the power to eat a
donut and and your skinny friends like
we'll just eat the Tona then what's big
to you Janet if you want we should
totally go ahead and have yourself never
to know that if you like that [ __ ] you
you don't get it it's a whole spiral
that begins with the donut later on
killing hookers I don't even more what
happened but so here's what happens you
get fat and your pants start to get
tight right and then you get fatter cuz
it's not like we'll stop eating now you
know
and then suddenly all your pants [ __ ]
hurt like every pair pants hurts and
then you eat even more because it's like
[ __ ] it no man who even cares match
shit's [ __ ] obsessed with food I went
to this [ __ ] thing with my wife and
kids where it was like the kids and
their kid friends and just a houseful of
[ __ ] you know that have kids
and I'm just standing there fine I just
want to kill myself and I just want a
bomb to drop on the whole house to take
us all out and I get in there but then
there's a plate of cookies and like it
stirs I'm like that's what I'm dumb
eating every [ __ ] cookie on that play
that's what I'm here that's what this
all is is [ __ ] that so and I you have
to have a strategy you know you can't
just [ __ ] you can't just [ __ ]
stand there just [ __ ] it you got you
have to like sort of keep rediscovering
the cookies you know yeah you do this
this means like I totally could not eat
it but I [ __ ] I'll do this I don't want
to hurt people's feelings brother cookie
totally [ __ ] radar back there okay
new people around the dish do it again
[Applause]
if people start noticing you have to say
something like these are crazy like I
might think I don't know what it is
about them yeah it's the [ __ ] cookies
it's not you're a piece of [ __ ] that
can't stop eating anything but um so
here's what happens so you get fat
enough though what happens is your belly
starts to push out like this and then it
pushes your pants down to your pelvis
because they won't hang in the normal
place anymore and then down there that
you're they feel loose and you start
going at a losing weight my pants are
getting loose I am getting thinner I ate
my way through to the other side I did
you know I don't give a [ __ ] I'm fat
look at this [ __ ] I don't [ __ ] care
look at that I don't care it's just a
sweaty bowl of [ __ ] flesh I don't
care
look how [ __ ] up this is - it goes
right in like it goes at a right angle
it hits my pelvis
it doesn't like slope back down it goes
in and then back up it's [ __ ] up like
when I'm in the shower and I'm scrubbing
like this if when I get in there I gotta
turn in like this I gotta actually make
a turn I can cut in or the crevice gets
[ __ ] filthy it's ridiculous it is
it's like a theater seat just like
[ __ ] receipts ooh [ __ ] and popcorn
[Applause]
in kids toys now [ __ ] what the hell